hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich sitze gerade im Auto mit
serio hallo wir befinden uns gerade auf
dem Weg nach Amsterdam weil wir dort auf
einem Event eingeladen sind ich Block
das ganze auch deswegen habe ich auch
dieses Kamera dabei allerdings habe ich
Vollidiot vergessen ein Video vor zu
produzieren deswegen habe ich euch bei
Instagram gesagt dass sie mir doch mal
bitte einige
oder was ist das eigentlich für den
Sommer
wo ich fünf war habe ich mir im
Kindergarten in die Hose Durchfall
gemacht und dann musste meine Lehrerin
ist abwischen
hallo Luca ich bin Pia und ich bin 12
ich habe mit fünf früher Popel an meine
weiße Wand geklebt und einmal kam mein
Vater rein und sagte was ist das an
deiner Wand ich antwortete meine
popeland
gegessen heute immer noch ehrlich ich
beichte dass mein Kopf so aussieht wie
ein Hals
[Musik]
hey Luca ich bin Lena 15 und als ich ca
8 Jahre alt war ist mir ein Zahn
rausgefallen weil ich ausgerutscht bin
und ich habe ihn gegessen am Abend als
ich Hunger hatte
keine Ahnung ich bin Carla und als ich
fünf war habe ich Bambus gegessen und
habe so getan als wäre ich ein Huhn und
ich bin auf einem Baum geklettert und
kam nicht mehr runter
ich glaube die haben mich an der Nase
herum gefühlt eine Freundin von mir
hatte ihr erstes Mal mit 14 auf dem
Schulklo mit einem der zwei Klassen über
ihr ist
glaube ich das stimmt
ich und mein Bruder haben ein Ritual
dass wir immer wenn wir am Meer sind im
Urlaub ins Meer kacken einmal das klingt
jetzt komisch aber machen wir for real
so ist halt irgendwie lustig
[Musik]
mehr geschissen aber es ist nicht meine
Ritual dass ich das richtig männlich 12
beichte dass ich im Kindergarten neben
die Klobrille geschissen habe weil das
Kind vor mir nicht runter gespielt hat
einfach runter für das so egal
hallo Luca ich beichte dass ich mit 6
Jahren von der Red Bull Dose kotzen
musste und es dann einfach richtig auf
getrunken habe damit die Schule
schwänzen konnte
gar nicht klar kommst immer wenn du
keinen Bock hast so schlau gemacht aber
dann kurzzeitig die ganze Zeit auch
nicht so geil
[Musik]
ich weiblich beichte dass ich bis ich 12
war mit einem Kissen geknutscht habe und
mir vorgestellt habe es ist der beste
Freund meines Vaters
sie sich vorgestellt dass ihr Kissen der
beste Freunde ist
weibliche Person
als ich mal in der Schule war habe ich
mir in die Hose gepisst und geschissen
und habe gesagt dass mein Sitznachbar
mich mit Wasserbomben abgeworfen hat und
dass er seine Kacke in mir geschoben hat
ich war nie so ein Mensch der sich so
ich war immer schon so ich war ich
männlich 12 beichte dass ich mit sieben
an den Unterhosen meiner Mutter
geschnüffelt habe und meine Mutter mich
mal erwischt hat
[Musik]
alles gar nicht stimmen
ich weiblich 14 beichte dass mein
Stiefbruder auf mich steht ich aber
nicht auf ihn und deswegen ist der sauer
auf mich einfach sauer sein steht
hi ich bin männlich 19 und habe am
gleichen Tag wo ich meine jetzige
Freundin kennengelernt habe mit ihrer
besten Freundin Sex auf einem Feld
gehabt
am gleichen Tag also ich kann auch eine
Story von einer Freundin dass der Typ
der mit dir zusammen gekommen ist
zusammen gekommen
als ich neun war und ich Schlittenfahren
war musste ich extrem furzen und habe
während des rutschen gepresst und
geschrien um es zu verstecken habe aber
nicht gefurzt sondern Dünnschiss gehabt
so eine Skihose reinscheißen flüssig hey
Luca als ich fünf war habe ich einen
Sonnenblumenkern gegessen und dann ist
der in mir gekeimt und dann hatte ich
eine Sonnenblume in mir drin
geht sowas nein wegen meinem Sohn ich
hatte
einfach irgendein Wort gesagt dass sie
irgendwie schlauer Leute Roman was ist
die Säure
hat mit einer Freundin telefoniert und
sie musste kurz weg und plötzlich kam
ihr Dad nackt ins Zimmer
und ein Mädchen und ich beichten dass
ich im Kindergarten Steine gefressen
habe
warum haben wir diese
trocken ich beichte dass ich meinen
kleinen Bruder früher mit meiner Scheiße
gefüttert habe und meinte es sei Schoko
Eis
ich männlich 15 beichte dass ich einmal
in der vierten Klasse mir in die Hose
geschissen habe und die Hose den
Rucksack meiner Lehrerin gesteckt habe
und die ganze Klasse hat den stinkenden
Florian verpetzt und er musste nach
Hause gehen
warum warum hat jede Beichte von euch
mit Scheiße zu tun ich männlich 13
beichte dass ich Sandra mehr mag als
dich man kann sich identifizieren was
man selber ist
Perspektive ich habe mal meiner
Schwester an die Kirschen und den Arsch
gepackt und massiert
wie geht's euch da hinten ich männlich
16 beichte dass ich laserluca abmontiert
habe
montiert
war war ich auf dem Schulhof und dann
kam ein Junge von hinten und hat meine
Hose ausgezogen und jeder hat meinen
Schwanz gesehen das war peinlich bitte
anonym danke
aber ich habe als ich acht war im Pool
das grüne gegessen und dann ist es
hinten wieder rausgekommen habe aber zum
Arzt gesagt es ist Spinat
ich höre in Holland alles dreht sich im
Käse Blumen und Drogen als ich sechs war
habe ich mal jemanden aus meiner Klasse
getötet und mein Vater musste deswegen
für sieben Jahre ins Gefängnis
hey Luca ich habe mal mit 4 Jahren
Regenwasser aus der Dachrinne zum
Zähneputzen verwendet und danach musste
ich übel kotzen hat er drei Tage lang
Durchfall immer kotzen und scheißen nur
Kotze und scheiße
dass ich als ich in der ersten Klasse
Grundschule war nein hör auf mir sitzen
ich meine Englischlehrer bis aufs Klo
gefolgt bin und ihn dabei beobachtet
habe wie er gerade dabei war
was heißt dabei
[Musik]
wolltest du auch mal so Lehrerzimmer mal
gehen ich war da
also meine Beichte ist dass ich mal mit
einer Freundin als ich acht war bei
Leuten geklingelt habe und denen gesagt
habe dass wir für unsere Grundschule
Geld sammeln und dass wir von den Geld
wollen naja also ein paar haben uns Geld
gegeben am Ende haben dass die Eltern
von meiner Freundin herausgefunden und
wir haben mies Anschiss bekommen
eine kleine Schwester war früher
besessen von diesem schokokügelchen wir
nannten die immer Hasen könnte aus
irgendeinem komischen Grund haha zur
gleichen Zeit hatten wir auch Ziegen und
wir haben ihr gesagt dass der Code von
den Ziegen diese Schoko Cornflakes sind
und sie hat daraufhin einfach die Kacke
unserer Ziegen gegessen
alles mit Kacke zu tun ich weiblich 15
habe als Kind mal ins Bad geschissen
nein wieder irgendwas mit ins Bad
geschissen Teppich voll scheiße Katze
tschüss halte das nächste mal eure
beichten bitte lieber für euch und
kriegt eure Verdauung im Griff
richtig
sehr wichtig
ich war gleich